was hältst du von organspenden für nicht
sinnvoll
ich bin organ schneller und auch schon
seit langer zeit ich bin organspender
tatsächlich wenn du stirbst würdest du
dann deine organe spenden
ja wenn die brauchbar sind ja ja was
bringen ja nichts mehr nicht tot nicht
oder asthma ganz spenderausweis dabei
allein
ich habe dem portemonnaie um mein
portemonnaie league zuhause
knochenmarkspende
du hast nicht der richtige ok also wenn
ich jetzt mit diesem partner sterbe wenn
ich kein organspender ausgedruckt und
selbst zusammengeklebt vorhin also ja
ich hatte bis vorhin keinen dabei weil
ich ein neues portemonnaie ab und da hat
es nicht reingepasst kein eine gute
ausrede ist den habe ich noch nicht
lange aber seitdem immer bei mir heute
möchte ich mit euch mal beim thema
sprechen dass ich für sehr sehr wichtig
halte aktuell warten in deutschland
circa 9.000 patienten auf ein
spenderorgan
es werden aber jedes jahr nur ungefähr
1000 organe gespendet
jeden tag sterben drei menschen weil sie
nicht rechtzeitig ein spenderorgan
erhalten
letzte woche am 16 januar hat sich der
deutsche bundestag gegen einen
gesetzesentwurf entschieden welcher
dafür gesorgt hätte dass alle bürger
automatisch organspender werden sofern
sie keinen widerspruch einlegen
das nennt man auch opt out man hat die
option auszusteigen ist aber erstmal
automatisch drin und somit spender
aktuell haben wir in deutschland das
opt-in oder zustimmungsverfahren man
muss sich aktiv melden und ja sagen um
spender zu werden so wie viele von euch
habe ich mich erst mal darüber aufgeregt
dass so entschieden wurde
das ist ja klar dass in einem opt out
system viel mehr menschen spender wären
das zeigen statistiken wie zum beispiel
diese hier mit opt out würde man also
viele tausende menschenleben retten
und dennoch bin ich mir nach einiger
recherche gar nicht mehr so sicher ob
der bundestag nicht vielleicht doch die
richtige entscheidung getroffen hat
warum das so ist darum geht es jetzt bei
doktor watson
[Musik]
als allererstes sollte eins klar gemacht
werden dein körper gehört dir und nur du
kannst eine entscheidung darüber treffen
ob du organspender sein willst oder
nicht das ist eine sehr persönliche und
individuelle entscheidung die jeder für
sich ausmachen muss und ich habe
vollstes verständnis dafür wenn man sich
bewusst dagegen entscheidet aus
religiösen gründen weil man sich damit
nicht wohl fühlt wieso auch immer total
egal
trotzdem sollte man zumindest informiert
sein um ein bekanntes missverständnis
direkt aus dem weg zu räumen
viele menschen machen sich sorgen dass
bei einer organspende das benötigte
organ zu früh entnommen werden könnte
und sie somit das eigene leben kosten
könnte das ist aber eigentlich unmöglich
denn es ist erst möglich die organe zu
entnehmen wenn der patient für hirntot
erklärt wurde
das bedeutet dass es keine möglichkeit
mehr für den patienten gibt wieder zum
leben zu erwachen mann ist definitiv
unwiderruflich tot
im falle eines klinischen todes ist es
zwar in seltenen fällen möglich wieder
aufzuwachen
hier ist es aber genau deswegen nicht
erlaubt organe zu entnehmen
auch die angst dass ärzte einen früher
aufgeben und für hirntot erklären um die
organe einem anderen patienten geben zu
können ist irrational
wenn ein patient für tot erklärt wird
müssen dass immer zwei ärzte unabhängig
voneinander machen
die dürfen dann auch nicht bei der
entnahme der organe beteiligt sein und
auch nicht entscheiden wer die organe zu
spenden das bekommt die regeln sind hier
sehr sehr streng
2003 haben eric johnson und deren
justine eine ziemlich interessante
studie durchgeführt manchen teilnehmern
der studie haben sie gesagt dass der
default also die standardeinstellung sei
dass man organspender ist danach haben
sie gefragt ob die teilnehmer dem
widersprechen möchten um zu nicht
spendern zu werten anders herum haben
sie anderen teilnehmern gesagt dass
diese standardmäßig keine spender wären
aber zustimmen könnten um spender zu
werden
wichtig ist hier dass sich die
teilnehmer der studie mit der
problematik auseinandergesetzt haben das
waren also informierte entscheidungen
die getroffen wurden und dennoch der
standard also der default wie die
forscher ihn nennen hat einen riesigen
einfluss auf die entscheidung der
teilnehmer
noch interessanter eine dritte gruppe
teilnehmer konnte eine entscheidung ohne
default treffen ihm wurde eine komplett
neutrale frage gestellt möchtest du
organspender werden ja oder nein
in dieser gruppe fanden sich
erstaunlicherweise fast genauso viele
organspender wie in der hauptgruppe die
widersprechen mussten in der echten welt
ist dieser effekt tatsächlich sogar noch
krasser in deutschland besitzen ungefähr
36 prozent der menschen einen solchen
organspenderausweis von denen wiederum
72 prozent zustimmen dass sie ihre
organe nach dem tod gerne spenden
möchten
in österreich hingegen wo das
widerspruchsverfahren gilt sind über 99
prozent der menschen organspender kaum
jemand widerspricht dort das ist der
effekt des diepholz und an dieser stelle
würde mich mal interessieren wie viele
von euch einen organspendeausweis haben
und wie viele nicht dazu gerne mal hier
oben die umfrage beantworten dich
erstellt habe mich würde interessieren
ob die typischen doktor watson zuschauer
er organspender sind oder eher nicht
die methode des opt out verfahrens wie
es zum beispiel in österreich verwendet
wird kennt man allerdings auf unter
einem anderen namen touch in ein match
also auf deutsch einen stups ist eine
methode um das verhalten von menschen zu
beeinflussen und zwar ohne verbote ohne
gebote oder bezahlung ein gutes beispiel
hierfür sind bilder auf
zigarettenpackungen um einen gesünderen
lebensstil zu fördern verpflichtet der
staat alle zigarettenhersteller die
packungen mit abstoßenden bildern zu
versehen
die idee wer wirklich rauchen will der
kann das immer noch tun
aber hoffentlich kann man so einige
leute um stimmen auch könnte man
überlegen das gesunde essen in der
schulkantine weiter nach vorne zu
stellen während die ungesunden
süßigkeiten schwieriger zu erreichen
sind
okay das klingt ja erst mal ganz
praktisch man wird in die richtige
richtung geschubst
die museen forscher wie zum beispiel
drei fertig vom max planck institut für
bildungsforschung in berlin
die gefahr dass nadine ausarten kann
hinter dem namen steht eine gewisse
vorstellung von psychologische
entscheidungs forschung in der
vordergrund steht dass menschen relativ
schlecht sind wenn sie entscheidungen
treffen weil menschen so viele fehler
machen und so schlecht sind
lassen wir es sozusagen einen teil ihrer
entscheidung jetzt durch die umwelt
machen das ist die idee von der
entscheidungs architektur und diese
umwelt stupst uns dann in bestimmte
richtung eine der befürchtungen hier ist
dass der staat hier als
paternalistischer staat auftritt das
heißt der staat sagt du ich weiß was gut
für dich ist du solltest organspende
sein und ich baue die entscheidungs
architektur so dass die
wahrscheinlichkeit größer ist das duo
auch organspende wirst es gibt leute die
argumentieren das matching immer am
rande der manipulation entlang
schlitterte der unterschied zur
manipulation ist dass der stupst ja
immer auf eine art und weise sein sollte
so dass der gestürzte immer die
möglichkeit hat zu sagen nein ich möchte
das nicht also der organspende der zum
organspender gemacht wird aber die
möglichkeit hat zu sagen eigentlich
möchten das nicht machen
und das ist der so genannte libertär
mitteilt ist es diese dieses konstrukt
libertäre paternalismus das ist
sozusagen die philosophie die politische
philosophie die dahinter steht aber
diese paternalistische komponente und
die libertäre komponente menschliche
schwächen fehler und defizite könnten
also ausgenutzt werden um dich und mich
in eine bestimmte richtung zum naschen
in einem opt out system gilt jede person
die nicht widerspricht ist erstmal
automatisch organspender
da der widerspruch mit aufwand verbunden
ist geht man davon aus dass nur wenige
leute widersprechen werden
aber das ist bevormunden kritiker
argumentieren dass der mensch so als
träges faules wesen angesehen wird dass
keine eigenen entscheidungen treffen
kann
viel sinnvoller wäre die alternative zum
lodging das posting
hierbei sollen die kompetenzen der
menschen verbessert werden eine freie
und informierte entscheidung eines
mündigen bürgers ist das ziel in der
forschung von eric johnson und der in
dresden konnte man auch sehen dass das
funktioniert wenn sich menschen mit der
thematik auskennen und selber eine
entscheidung treffen dann entscheiden
sie sich fast genauso oft für das
spenden von organen
die menschen im ort system nur dass
diese menschen die entscheidung selber
und aktiv getroffen haben und ich denke
das ist die kernfrage diese diskussion
kann man menschen zutrauen ihre eigenen
entscheidungen zu treffen
klingt erst mal witzig aber wenn man
sich die statistik ansieht dann kann man
das scheinbar nicht viel zu viele leute
sind zu faul ihren default zu ändern der
ihnen zugesprochen wird wie hier in
deutschland sind zu großen teilen kein
organspender weil es der standard ist
dass man kein organspender ist auf der
anderen seite kann man nicht einfach
über die köpfe der menschen hinweg
entscheiden
gut könnte man jetzt argumentieren das
macht man ja auch gar nicht man kann
sich zu jedem zeitpunkt bewusst dagegen
entscheiden
aber schweigen gilt nach deutschem recht
nicht als willenserklärung menschen die
sich nicht äußern
sollten weiterhin keine spender sein
denn sonst wäre es ja auch keine spende
keine freiwillige zuwendungen ohne
gegenleistung
vor diesem hintergrund finde ich die
entscheidung des bundestages
nachvollziehbar
die lösung des problems sollte nicht
sein zu hoffen dass sich möglichst
wenige menschen die mühe machen zu
widersprechen
die lösung sollte sein menschen zu
informieren und sie selber eine
entscheidung treffen zu lassen und das
ist auch genau das was der bundestag
jetzt entschieden hat unter anderem eine
neutrale frage wie zum beispiel gestellt
wird wenn man das erste mal seinen
personalausweis bekommt möchtest du
organspender sein ja oder nein mit infos
zum thema organspende und keinem druck
von irgendeiner seite
trotzdem ist das eine menge arbeit und
wird viele jahre dauern ein opt out
system hätte jetzt sofort menschenleben
gerettet
kann man das gegeneinander aufwiegen
viele leute sagen dass die fünf minuten
die es dauert um zu widersprechen in
keinem verhältnis zu einem geretteten
menschenleben stehen sie die das genauso
das würde mich auf jeden fall mal sehr
interessieren auch das system mit dem
organspendeausweis ist veraltet und
funktioniert oft nicht man kann ihn zum
beispiel verlieren oder die schrift
darauf ist nicht mehr lesbar
deswegen soll es in zukunft einen online
portal geben auf dem man sich und seine
entscheidung zur organspende eintragen
und jederzeit bearbeiten kann
das kommt allerdings erst in einigen
jahren deswegen wenn du kein problem
damit hast deine organe nach deinem tod
zu spenden
dann werde bitte spender hol dir einen
organspenderausweis zb kostenlos auf
einer website wie dieser hier ich habe
unten verlinkt für den
organspendeausweis aus und stecken denn
dein portemonnaie spricht auch gerne mit
freunden und verwandten über das thema
damit alle wissen wie deine
stellung dazu ist denn die wohl größte
errungenschaft der demokratie ist die
freiheit über das eigene schicksal und
den eigenen körper entscheiden zu dürfen
und ich persönlich kann mir nichts
wichtigeres vorstellen als diese
freiheit zu nutzen um menschenleben zu
retten
bei diesem video gibt's übrigens keinen
sponsor keiner gibt uns geld dafür dass
wir das hier erzählen es ist uns einfach
nur wichtig darüber zu sprechen und es
ist hierbei trend itu aufgefallen dass
wir zwar eine sehr große fans von
organspenden sind aber nur die wenigsten
von uns tatsächlich einen
organspenderausweis mit uns tragen die
ganze zeit deswegen wir jetzt auf der
website die ich für ein verlinkt habe
sechs stück bestellt wir werden die
ausfüllen
wir werden ins portemonnaie stecken und
immer dabei haben um organspender zu
sein und wir hoffen möglichst viele von
euch machen mit um hoffentlich leben
retten zu können
wie immer vielen dank fürs zuschauen und
bleibt neugierig patrick